lassen Sie uns doch heute mit einer
kleinen Bibelstunde beginnen und mit
einem Zitat aus der Bibel es ist in
keinem anderen heil denn in dem Namen
Jesu zur Ehre Gottes des Vaters das in
dem Namen Jesu sich beugen sollen aller
derer Knie die im Himmel und auf Erden
und unter der Erde sind er diesen Satz
diesen Text an der Kuppel des nachgebaut
Berliner Stadtschlosses möchte grünen
Politikerin Claudia Roth nun
vorübergehend überblenden der Grund die
Kulturbeauftragte der Bundesregierung
hält den Bibeltext für nicht weltoffen
und unangemessen also gerade hier in
Deutschland ist er ja geprägt durch die
christlichen Glauben wir sind ja auch
sehr tolerant wir wissen ja dass wir in
einigen Moscheen und auch in Köln ja
sehr tolerant sind in Köln
also man kann uns nicht vorwerfen dass
dass wir nicht tolerant sind aber wir
müssen es auch zu unserer eigenen Kirche
und zwar unserem eigenen Land natürlich
be